hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be looking at the rylopez
steinitz defense the right lopez starts
out with e4
e5 net f3
knight c6 and bishop to b5 one of the
most common openings in all of chess and
the steiner's defense is d
six now this is thought to be a very
solid but passive defense from black the
way i play it though i'm always looking
for aggressive lines so we're gonna be
looking at those lines and how i like to
attack it sometimes you may hear about a
modern stein it's defense
that's when you're playing a6 kicking
the bishop back to a4 and then playing
d6 but we're looking at the og of the
steinis defense this is something that
you know 100 years ago all the world
champions were playing and that is just
d6 right away the four lines we are
going to be looking at the first one is
d4 this is the main line attacking the
center the second one is going to be
castling on the king side for white then
we're going to be looking at knight to
c3 normal development and then lastly
we're going to look at the bishop taking
on c6
before we jump into the variations a
quick word from our
sponsor our sponsor today is raid shadow
legends the mobile game with millions of
players online this game is all about
your champion my favorite champion is
turbo one of the hardest hitting damage
dealers in the game pretty much all his
skills are just pure direct damage which
i absolutely love and knowing that this
game is all about champions
raid's gonna be setting everyone up with
their own free epic hero and that is ana
just by clicking on the link in the
description below or the qr code you're
going to get ana you're also going to
get a lot of other perks worth 30
dollars in value this is for new players
in the next 30 days by clicking the link
once you go into the game in the top
right hand corner you'll see this icon
i'm pointing to you click on that and
you'll be set up with ana as well as the
other perks
the first variation we're going to look
at is if white plays d4 this is the most
common line and if i'm playing the rye
lopez as white and they play the steinis
defense i'm typically going to be
playing d4
and before we get into how black should
respond you first need to understand the
threats that white has let's say the
bishop on b5 pinning down this knight so
white's looking to push forward with d5
doubling up the attack on
c6 but if black were to play let's say
a6 attacking the bishop here black's
going to lose the center exchange so
bishop takes pawn takes and then after
the pawn takes if black takes on e5 well
then the queens are going to exchange
off the board and then knight takes e5
with the threat of taking on f7 forking
the rook and the king as well as
attacking the pawn on c6 you can see
white's already up a pawn of material
that's not going to work the only other
option black could try is if instead of
this exchange on e5 maybe they play
bishop g4 trying to pin down the knights
well white has the move queen d4 and you
say what exactly is this move doing
let's say after the bishop takes pawn
takes f3
now if the pawn takes e5
then white can take with the queen here
check
and then after the queen e7 then we
could just see the queen come back here
and you can see white is up still that
pawn in material as well as if you look
at black situation they have double
pawns on the c file and they're isolated
so it's not too bad if you have double
pawns as long as they're not isolated
meaning as long as they have a pawn on
either side of it preferably on this d
file
so if we come back uh maybe we don't do
a six
from from black what if we do h6 kind of
give you an idea from the other side
okay well then the pawn can just take in
the center of the board bishop takes
pawn recaptures queen takes here and you
can see it's still not going to work so
black has to have other ideas than
playing
a6 h6 anything besides attacking this
pawn on d4 so black's going to be taking
here on d4
most common line from white is to
capture with their knight on d4
and then black's going to be playing
bishop to d7
now here is where i start to play a
little bit different than people have in
the past
usually white's going to castle on the
king's side they could play knight to c3
and a lot of players would play bishop
to e7 here then knight to f6 castle on
the king side you can see it starts to
get to be a cramped position
instead i really like playing
g6 now we're fianchettoing our bishop to
g7
we can get our knight involved into the
game castle on the king side you can see
it's more of a modern approach where
we're using our bishop on g7 gives us a
little bit more breathing room and then
we control these dark squares in the
center of the board you can see white
does not have their central uh dark
square which is typically on the d4
square
and so this is a good setup here we also
have the bishop on d7 blocking
this attack on
the c6 square and so at the end of the
day this is the approach that i like to
use if they play
that pawn to d4 early on
the next variation we're going to look
at is if white castles on the king side
and in this variation i like to get
pretty aggressive and play something you
don't see all that often and that is the
move g5 it starts to put a lot of
pressure on our opponent once we play g4
now knowing that we're extending on the
king side white's almost always going to
play d4 if they don't i think it's a big
mistake for them they have the better
pawn structure controlling the center of
the board is really all they need to do
but black's looking to be pretty
aggressive going against what you would
typically think in the old stynets
defense but that's okay after g4 white
has three different options one they
could try to get aggressive with their
knight knight to g5 it is protected by
the bishop on c1 it could just come back
on e1 and say okay yeah go ahead and
take the advantage right now i'm going
to bring back my development to the
first rank here
or they could just counter-attack
themselves and say you know d5 say if
you want to attack our knight that's
fine i'm going to go ahead and attack
your knight so we're going to look at
all three of those if they play d5 we're
going to play a6 now they could take
with their pawn or their bishop if they
take with their pawn it's probably worse
we take with our pawn we're still
attacking
their knights and that's key to remember
here if they don't take our pawn on b7
it's pretty much just a free pawn for us
so that's going to be good and they
still have to worry about their knight
here
uh the only way they can even
not worry about their knight right away
is if they play pawn takes b7 because
now they're attacking our bishop and our
rook so we have to deal with that but we
take it with our bishop and all of a
sudden our bishop is in a really good
spot it's in a great square it's
attacking the long light square diagonal
not a very good position for white now
if they take with their bishop instead a
little bit better but you usually don't
want to be giving up your bishops early
in the game we take with our pawn now
maybe they played knight to
uh g5 is one option
but we play
h6 and it gets tricky because what do
they do they just sacrifice on f7
there's no other good square this is
another position where they're almost
forced to just come back to e1
then we take on d5 they take with their
pawn and then bishop g7
and you can see white has no pieces
developed past this second rank here
except the pawn on d5 where black has a
lot going on yes they don't have the
strongest king side protection
with the the pawns but that's okay
there's a lot that black has going for
it and this is not your typical
passive defense
now if we come back let's say they don't
play d5 let's say they recognize their
knights under attack and so they play
knight to g5
okay well first we can go ahead and take
their pawn here let's say they take with
their queen
then we can play f6 that queen was
attacking our rokon h8 so this not only
stops that but it also attacks the
knight on g5
so that's something to keep in mind then
we can get our bishop involved into the
game this is a pretty good setup for us
we can also if we want to get our light
square bishop volume to the game a6 at
some point to attack the bishop but
that's how i would do it if they play
knight to
g5 if instead of bringing the queen to
d4 maybe they play bishop c4
putting their knight and their bishop
both attacking the pawn on f7 in that
case i would play knight two h6 this
knight defends the pawn on f7
but instead of playing knight to e5
because now the queen can capture on d4
so this knight also protects the f7
square but i really like keeping the
knight on c6 it's no longer pinned by
the bishop on b5 and so it still
protects the pawn here on d4
so last thing we're going to look at is
if they come back to knight e1
okay well now they've moved their knight
twice it's back on the e1 square it's
blocking the rook from f1 getting
involved into the game so this is where
black really needs to be aggressive you
probably can guess right away we're
gonna take that pawn on d4 trying to
control the center of the board
if they take with their queen we can't
capture with our knight if you look at
and say why would they actually play
that our knight is being pinned down by
the bishop that's fine but now we can
play knight to f6 here maybe bishop g5
pinning down our knight to the queen but
then bishop g7
always want to be looking to bring our
bishop to g7 fiance and really that
modern approach of controlling the
center by putting our minor pieces on
the side aiming towards the center of
the board so that's how i approach it
early on
if our opponent plays
castle on the king side i like to be
very aggressive playing g5 not your
normal approach that you typically see
which is bishop to e7 potentially just
bishop d7 i think those are way too
passive and there's a more aggressive
approach and that's pawn g5
the next variation we're going to look
at is if white plays knight c3 simple
development move in this case we're
going to play bishop d7 we're not going
to push forward with g5 white has not
committed to the king side by castling
and so we don't want to do that right
away instead bishop d7 stopping the pin
right away
in this case they could decide to
capture we'll look at what happens if
they don't but if they do that's fine
hey we play bishop take c6 maybe now
they push in the forward with a d4 we're
going to play knight f6 maybe they
castle on the king side we could have an
exchange in the center of the board
although it looks like we are up upon a
material white is able to capture that
back rook to e1 attacking the bishop we
can exchange if we feel like we need to
bishop to e7 preparing to castle on the
king side pawn takes on e5 and after the
pawn takes uh maybe the rook takes on e5
and then we castle and part of the
reason i like castling here one you
always want to get king safety but it's
a trap
if you do reach this position if you
look at it white may say hey i can go
ahead and take this pawn on b7 but if
they take they would actually lose the
game queen to d1 the only way to stop it
is rook to e1 and then checkmate after
queen takes e1 so in this position the
queen can't actually capture both sides
are fairly equal in material we're
getting down towards the end game again
this is why i think this is one of the
the drawlish variations in the
steinnett's defense now if we come back
what if the bishop does not take because
not many people are going to be taking
on c6 although it does happen sometimes
but let's just say they try to control
the center with d4 since it is one of
the most common ways to continue we're
going to go ahead and take on d4 that's
almost always our go to
knight takes d4 we're going to play g6
remember we're always going to be
looking to bring our bishop to g7
fianchetto control the center with the
dark square with the bishop on g7 and
then castle on the king side
the last variation we're going to look
at is if the bishop takes on c6 now some
players will never give up their bishop
early on i think that is a good decision
i think just giving up your bishop is a
poor move here but sometimes they'll
look at and say hey you have double
pawns just know that double pawns are
not always bad especially if they're
towards the center of the board and
they're not isolated meaning they do
have pawns on either side of them
instead this can actually really control
the center and make it more difficult
for your opponent let's say they played
knight to c3 which we just looked at
previously knight to c3 gets difficult
because of c5 now we completely control
this d4 square they can't just play d4
we take it now it's protected by the
pawn so they can't even even though they
have both the knight and the queen
attacking this they can't take on d4 we
completely control it so they really
can't play c3 knight to c3 that's a poor
move let's say they play d4 okay well
now we can just go ahead and take with
their pawn they take over their queen we
play knight to f6 they play knight to c3
here
but then how do they really break
through we can
be in keto at some point uh more than
likely though at this point because of
their queen on d4 it gets a little
tricky when you start fianchettoing to
the king side if their queen is on d4 we
could always kick it away something like
pawn c5 but we also have the option of
bishop to e7 castle on the king side
more of a traditional approach of king
side safety we're definitely not going
to be castling on the queen side and
then our bishop at any time can get
involved into the game so that is
the steinitz defense in the rye lopez
this is the old steinis defense if you
guys want to see a video on the modern
approach which at the beginning of the
game
instead of just the d6 right away is
more that a6 forcing the bishop to come
back here and then playing d6 happy to
make a video on that as well uh but
hopefully this gives you some ideas on
how you can play d6 and feel confident
that you have a great position
that you don't have to just play the
passive lines and you actually have some
aggressive ways to combat white's line
so thank you guys so much for watching
the video thank you to the sponsor
for this video let me know in the
comments below what you thought of this
and if you have any other
recommendations for future videos but
thanks again i'll see you guys in the
next video